Austin llin bercier had an adventurer
spirit and humanitarian Soul he was
always like a community person like he
always liked going out like volunteering
he was in the Canadian Armed Forces
bolded Eagles as a teen a summer
training program for indigenous youth
from western Canada and Northwestern
Ontario with plans to join the
Infantry but while Laughlin berer was
traveling abroad in 2022 Russia invaded
Ukraine he felt he couldn't just stand
by while a sovereign country was
attacked by an authoritarian regime he
flew to Poland then crossed into Ukraine
to join the fight I think mainly he went
there because he seen like on the news
of how many innocent women and children
were being killed and for him like he's
always been protected of a women
children and even like those who
couldn't defend themselves or can't
defend themselves he kept loved ones
updated with texts and social media
posts his final words to his mom all
good here two days later on Remembrance
Day the worst news my mom called me and
let me know that he was
gone Manitoba Premier wob canoe is among
the many calling the 25-year-old a hero
a pasque out creation says he will be
honored as one I'm sure it's going to be
a big event not just from this community
but people the armed services community
and probably the Ukrainian Community
Laughin bier's family is coordinating
with the Canadian government for his
remains to return home to be buried next
to his grandmother Melissa Rin Global
News Winnipeg